is the excelsior starship the most
successful starship ever designed by the
federation and what the hell is going on
with its transwarp capabilities
welcome to sidetrek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
so i'm going to start by saying the
excelsior is one of my favorite designs
i think it's a stunning looking ship um
the undiscovered country is actually
probably my favorite star trek film
because i saw it at the cinema on my own
for the first time it was the first star
trek film i ever actually saw on the big
screen and that whole opening sequence
with the shock wave and the excelsior
turning into it i just i just loved it
captain sulu on the bridge fire apart
then
everything about this ship i absolutely
adore and it's a starship that survived
within the federation on the front line
for over a century it was basically
designed at the end of the 2280s and was
still in service and at the front line
in service during the battle of wolf 359
and again at during the dominion wars
even though most of the time it was
getting into ascended to it or just
getting straight or blown up
the excelsior was still there it was
still getting upgraded even 100 years
after it first commissioned
an excelsior-class starship went up
against the defiant they went toe-to-toe
and it was able to hold its own
but let's discuss the element in the
room the grand experiment the trans-warp
capability
because there are a couple of schools of
thought on this now first of all you
don't actually ever hear them say
transwarp
in the actual films they're the search
for spock you'll hear captain styles
sort of having a little jab at kirk
saying that we're going to break all of
enterprise's speed records tomorrow
but
that doesn't necessarily mean trans war
passing going beyond warp 10 or what we
understand from the next generation is
warp 10. we know this basically because
in the original series the enterprise
traveled beyond warp 10 several times in
2267 when they came in contact with the
nomad probe the probe was able to
improve the antimatter injectors and the
enterprise was able to travel a warp
14.1
now i would argue that that actually
probably wasn't warp 14.1 but it was
actually more likely what nine or 9.5
something along those lines
we also know from
the final episode of the next generation
all good things that the uss pasteur
traveled at warp 13. now i know you're
going to argue that that wasn't really
canon because it did it or didn't happen
we're not sure if it was time travel or
just
imagine or q playing games
but it would make sense we know the
enterprise d was able to travel as a
maximum of what nine point nine five the
end voyager had a cruising speed of what
nine point nine six seven i think uh
someone's going to correct me in the
comments i probably got that wrong um
and starships are getting faster and
faster
it doesn't make any sense that 10 15 20
years after the next generation a
captain would go engage at what 9.99953
henson
they're not going to do that they're
going to change the scale at some point
so even though warp 10 would still
become the maximum they're going to have
to sort of create some extra numbers in
there so the captain isn't saying
ridiculous
0.67352 please
so warp 11 warp 12 warp 13 would be in
tng standards or
9.99995 whatever
we also know though that we have trans
warp conduits with the borg but again it
doesn't think we're actually traveling
beyond warp 10 these just seem to be
traveling
9.9996 something when the traveler
pushed the enterprise out into unknown
space again they weren't traveling
beyond warp 10 they were traveling at
what 9.9 some ridiculous figure
so is the excelsior actually a transwarp
drive or was it just a new warp drive
that then was actually used in all
starships
well
the star trek the next generation actual
technical manual did call the excelsior
the failed experiment
they were actually look like they were
trying to use a mixture between
transporter technology and warped coils
to create a vessel that could travel
into interphasic space
this was a technology that they came
across in the original series during the
antholian encounter
and the enterprise actually used
interphasic space to travel a vast
distance beyond thorium space in a very
short period of time
that was when the excelsior experiment
began and they were looking into this
technology
it looks like that technology may have
actually worked but caused massive
stresses to the vessel and a significant
damage
micro factories through the hall may
have made this technology impossible to
pursue
or just impractical all massively
unreliable any of those reasons may have
caused the experiment to be classed as a
failure and for the design to be
abandoned we know that the excelsior did
have a large revamp before sulu became
captain we know this because the bridge
pod was completely changed and other
sections of the vessel seem to have been
modified was the transwarp drive
stripped out to that point
a more
contemporary warp system put in place
we also know that the lithium crystals
used in the original series enterprise
became unstable at high warp
was this a problem with unsolved
if you remember the um scotty episode or
with a dyson sphere where scotty is then
poking around the engine um of the
enterprise d
he says laddie you know your lithium
crystals are about to fracture and
[ __ ] jordy comes running over and
goes no no it's fine we've we modified
them completely you know we they're
they're constantly re-stabilized don't
don't worry get away from the engine you
all fart
it's ancient technology
if it wasn't for the technical manual
and saying that the excelsior vessel was
a failed experiment we'd have no reason
to believe that it was
in fact the enterprise d might be using
virtually the same engines that are
aboard the excelsior so what do we
actually know about the excelsior she
has 34 decks
meters long
186 meters wide captain stars commander
in 2285 while she's doing her space
trials smashing all those enterprise
records but she was then commissioned in
2287 as a regular frontline federation
starship sulu became captain by 2290.
she had type eight phases and anything
from six to eight photon torpedo bays
even though that's a little bit of a
problem there because
um on the technical manual it shows two
torpedo launchers but actually um when
we see the the vessel thing where we
believe some of the torpedo launchers
are actually look like shuttle bays the
doors are open and the shuttle's coming
out of them so we look like shield base
um
some people have argued though that i
mean the enterprise only really had one
forward-facing torpedo launcher so why
would the excelsior have anything up to
four or six
well i mean
the enterprise d photon torpedo launcher
was a multi-capable photon torpedo
launcher it could fire five torpedoes at
once you know you have that beautiful
thing and then there's splitting and
we can assume the excelsior could only
actually fire one at a time so in that
case
even if it had four forward-facing
photon torpedo launches
say that fast three times
it would still actually possibly have
less firepower than even one photon
torpedo launcher of the enterprise d
and it should be said
that the excelsior was designed as a
warship she's classed as a heavy cruiser
and she was designed as a direct result
of klingon activity this is during a
period of a cold war with the klingons
and it was expected that that war would
become hot at some point soon the
klingons were developing the katinga
heavy cruiser
and the federation were terrified
before that their most advanced capable
fighting machine was the warbird and we
had we were able to go toe-to-toe with
those vessels
but this new cruiser
was far more capable than the most
advanced starship the federation had at
the time which would be the constitution
class
the federation needed to design a heavy
cruiser and they needed it fast
hence the excelsior and potentially why
she is so heavily armored and also just
so damn big there are some really
interesting points about the excelsior
as well this is another one of those
starships that the saucer section could
separate
she actually has a battle bridge like
the enterprise d which tends to suggest
that this vessel was actually designed
with the separation in mind
but i suspect that was a last-ditch kind
of thing because
it's believed that the the source
section couldn't actually reconnect
without the use of a space dock or some
other support
so
in that case why was it done like that
well if it was done with a war in mind
with a possible conflict with the
klingons then it would be similar to how
the constitution would be able to
replace the sixth sorcerer section that
in an out and out conflict
the main drive section would separate
from the saucer the saucer section would
move out of the way
and the drive section a sleeker more
agile now fighting machine would go into
conflict
we also noticed that from when the
enterprise b and forwards was modified
we had the excelsior class part two if
you like with those little fins that
stuck out the side and everything
that they've actually put very large um
impulse engines on the source section
this was obviously to give the source
section
impulse is this again thing of creating
two targets was that a modification of
the design instead of the sources
section simply being there to escape and
the drive section going into battle was
it perhaps more like what the enterprise
d envisaged
that you could separate and become more
of a fighting machine
this is something the federation has
explored in other starships as well one
of the ugliest starships in history
going into separated mode for
multi-vector attack looking at the
actual
diagrams of the excelsior though there
was unfortunately no dolphins aboard
which
is a huge shame let's be honest so this
is a starship that was able to last 100
years in front line service
it was designed to be heavily upgradable
they literally pulled sections out and
put sections in this was a vessel with
an incredibly strong space frame and an
incredibly capable starship it went
toe-to-toe with enemies for over a
century you really really have to tip
your hat to any design that has that
capability so if you are new to the
channel please like subscribe hit that
bell notification it really helps us out
and
leave a comment what is your favorite
starship and do you know any little
tidbits about the excelsior that you
want to share with us all go join us on
facebook there is a link in the
description and go and join us on our
discord server and you can talk to lots
of other people about everything sci-fi
as always stay safe and i'll see you
next time
[Music]